Hi, I'm Thomas Farley, otherwise known as "Mister Manners"...
...and I'm an etiquette expert...
...who does workshops for corporations around the country,...
...teaching people to be more professional in the way they act at work.
I think a big thing that's changed today versus how it used to be...
...is the fact that most of us are working in open office spaces...
...so you really gotta be mindful of how your actions at your own desk...
...are affecting everybody around you.
And that could be anything from the food you eat,...
...to the noise you're making when you're on the telephone, to the way you keep your desk.
A few of the things that are not always practiced, number one is noise level.
If you're on the telephone, you really should keep your volume down,...
...not just because you don't want people hearing what you're saying,...
...but also if you're taking a lot of personal phone calls,...
...you don't wanna be seen as the person who's constantly on the phone...
...handling personal stuff on company time.
The second thing is food smells.
Yay that you're eating your lunch at work...
...but the fact that you're eating a smelly sandwich,...
...a messy sandwich at your desk,...
...you're really involving everybody else around you...
...in ways they probably would rather not be involved.
If you got lunch and you're eating it at your desk,...
...try to keep it to something that's a little bit more scent neutral.
And otherwise, if you prefer a more spicy food that's a little stinkier,...
...you might wanna be eating that outside the office and not at your desk.